[MUSIC PLAYING]
ELLIE POWERS: Hey everybody.
So I'm Ellie Powers from
the Google Play team.
And thanks so much for cutting
your lunch a little bit
short to make it back here.
When I was 13 years old
and I was in middle school,
we read this book.
It was called "Lakota
Woman," and it
was this really powerful
story of a woman who
grew up in a Native American
reservation in South Dakota.
The place looked like this,
a really beautiful place.
But her story was completely
different from mine.
She went through all
sorts of struggles
that I'd never heard about.
And we read this book as
part of our larger unit
that we were doing on
Native American history.
And in order to
graduate seventh grade,
we had to complete a massive
independent research project.
I'd never done anything
like it before.
And after reading
her story I said,
I have to do my presentation
on Native American religious
freedom and oppression
in the United States
in the second half of the 1900s.
Because I was 13-year-old,
and I guess that's just what
made sense to me at the time.
So I went into the library.
I had procrastinated
a bit, I do admit.
So I tried to find books
that talked about the topic
that I wanted to write about.
And I really wanted to write
about individual stories
of people who had
experienced oppression
and had had struggles in
terms of being able to express
their religious beliefs.
And it wasn't so surprising,
looking back on it,
that I couldn't
find these books.
Because the information
was either too new, or it
was too controversial
to be published.
But luckily, I grew
up in Silicon Valley.
So even though my life
was a little bit weird,
it meant that I had some
tools that I could access
that helped me do
a little bit more
than I could have done
with my local library.
I want to introduce
you to my SPARCstation.
Anyone remember this computer?
This was the first
computer that I
had that could
access the Internet,
and it was back
in the early '90s.
And my family had
a Sun SPARCstation
that looked almost
exactly like this.
And this computer
was so awesome.
Not only did it
have a CD-ROM drive,
it also had a color screen.
It didn't have Firefox,
because that didn't exist.
But it had a three button mouse.
You can't even
buy those anymore.
I mean, three buttons.
That's 50% more efficient than
most mice on the market today.
And best of all, my
SPARCstation had a modem.
And I was one of
the first people
I knew who could
connect to the Internet.
The Internet wasn't amazing
back then like it is today,
and you couldn't do a lot.
But this was my first
chance to find information
that wasn't available
in my local library,
and to reach out to people who I
would have never met otherwise.
So when I was trying
to write my report
and I couldn't find
any books, at first
I thought I was
completely out of luck.
But then I realized that
my SPARCstation had Mosaic.
Do you remember Mosaic?
Do you remember these
dark gray backgrounds?
You remember them,
I can see that.
Do you remember the blue
links, and when you clicked
on them they turned purple?
I mean, that was awesome, right?
And I found Mosaic.
I could cruise
around a little bit.
And then, if you didn't have
Mosaic, maybe you had Gopher.
Do you remember Gopher?
It was like a lot of
folders, and you could just
go from one folder, the
next folder, another folder.
And sometimes you could
find images and text
in those folders, and send
your folders to your friends,
and tell them which
folders were the best.
This was really cool.
And it was through
these tools that I
stumbled onto something amazing
that solved all of my problems.
It was called NATCHAT,
Native American Chat.
And basically this is where
historians and other people
interested in Native
American issues
would go to talk
about anything related
to Native American culture.
So I started hanging
out in NATCHAT.
I got completely immersed
in a whole new world
that I had never
even heard of before.
I got all the information
that I needed for my project.
I interacted with new
people who had nothing to do
with my regular everyday life.
And I wrote my report.
Not only did I write
my report, but I
included all this
information I'd
learned from people that no one
in my school had learned about.
And I felt that I was able
to educate not only myself,
but also my teachers
and other students.
I felt so powerful.
And I said, this is great.
I've accomplished
something important,
and I want everyone else to
have the same experience.
So, of course--
remember, I was 13--
I taught my little siblings
how to use the computer.
I wanted them to have
that feeling too.
And that was cool, but
that wasn't enough either.
I wanted everyone to have
this great experience,
this feeling of connectedness.
And I thought, yup, sooner
or later, everyone's
going to have their own
SPARCstation just like me,
and this is going to be awesome.
But looking back, this
was never going to happen.
It wasn't going to be
possible that everyone
could have a SPARCstation.
If you look at the technology
that we have today,
it's so different from
that SPARCstation.
Let's do a couple comparisons.
So this SPARCstation, with its
awesome three button mouse,
thousands of dollars.
An Android One phone, which
is basically a supercomputer
in comparison, less than $100.
Obviously a huge benefit.
Do you guys remember
learning touch typing?
Mavis Beacon, and
you had to learn
how to press all those little
buttons in the right order?
That was actually hard,
looking back on it.
And today we have touch
screens and sensors.
They're so simple
that you don't even
have to teach young
kids how to start
using a phone or a tablet.
They just figure it out.
Back then, you had
your big SPARCstation
stuck on your desk.
There were tons of
wires coming out of it.
If the power ever went out,
you lost all your work.
But today, you can connect
anywhere in the world.
You can charge a phone
wherever you can.
It's so much better.
And this is great, because
back in the day only
a couple of super nerds could
connect to the Internet,
and I didn't think
that was fair.
I wanted all super nerds
to connect to the Internet.
In fact, I wanted everybody
And so this ability
to give people
the same powerful feeling
of connectedness and access
to information is actually
why I'm at Google.
I'm really excited to be
here because Google's mission
to organize the
world's information
and make it
universally accessible
is so deeply tied to
what's important to me,
and what has made a
difference in my own life.
And so what Google
Play is, is it's
what happens when
we've connected now,
literally, a billion people.
And we've given them access
to a connected catalog
of experiences.
And that catalog, and those
connected experiences,
are made possible by
developers like all of you.
And so now here we are, at
this special moment in history.
Developers can
have a huge impact
on both local and
global problems,
because everyone's
connected now.
And a lot of that
is through Android.
So I want to tell you a story
of some of these developers.
Our first story takes
us to Sao Paulo, Brazil.
And "Emprego Ligado" means
"jobs online" in Portuguese.
We actually have a
couple people here
from the Emprego Ligado team
today, which is pretty awesome.
And they're proud
to say that they
have made the number
one blue collar jobs
service in all of Brazil.
So let's learn a little bit more
about why this is important.
So Sao Paulo is home to 11.8
million people, and the worst
traffic jams in the world,
according to Time Magazine.
So Emprego Ligado
saw this common pain
point, this commute time in
Sao Paulo, it's just painful.
I mean, three hours.
That is a long time to spend
commuting every single day.
And the most common
way to get around
there is actually
on a public bus.
There's about 16,000
buses in Sao Paulo.
These buses are
often overcrowded.
It can be hard to get a seat.
And three hours a
day is a long time
to spend your life sitting on
a bus, or standing on a bus.
And so this is
some of the traffic
that you'll be spending
your time sitting through.
Luckily, it's a beautiful
city, and it even
has some cool murals to look at.
But I mean, that's just
a lot of your life.
And so Emprego Ligado
had a key insight.
Let's say we compare two people.
One person has this crazy
three hour daily commute.
Another person has a
more reasonable commute
of around one hour per day.
So if you do the
math, that basically
it means that the person
with the long commute
is wasting 20 business days
of their life commuting.
That's time when they're
not economically productive,
they can't earn money,
they can't spend time
with their family,
and it's creating
a huge financial and
psychological impact on them.
So Emprego Ligado was
founded back in 2012
by three college friends
who are incredibly
passionate about
Latin America and went
to live and work there.
Not only did they
see this problem,
that people were spending
a lot of time commuting,
and that that wasn't very
fun-- and actually, that
was leading to the
traffic problems
in the big cities of Brazil
getting worse and worse.
But also, employees had
an extremely inefficient
recruiting process.
And it was hard for them
to find the right employees
for their companies.
So the job market was
really broken, actually.
Job seekers had
no way to find out
about new jobs that
were available.
So, if you had a
job, you would just
stick it out, until
maybe you happened
to hear about something.
Maybe your friend tells you.
But until then, you were stuck.
And employers were
really struggling too.
They needed to find people
with the right experience.
And the commute time was the
top reason that a lot of people
left jobs.
There was a survey,
actually, that 37%
of people who were earning
a kind of low to middle wage
in the region, said
that they had actually
left a job due just to traffic.
No other reason,
just their commute.
And so imagine, if you had 37%
of your workforce potentially
leaving their job
at your company,
and you'd have to replace
them, just because
of the commuting situation.
I mean, that's tough.
And so they calculated
that-- let's say
we have a company with
about 100,000 employees.
So you could be losing
up to $80 million
a year due to employee turnover,
because of these retention
and recruitment difficulties.
But not only did they
see this problem.
They also saw an opportunity
to increase transparency
in the job market.
So they looked at
the job market.
And these are the most
common jobs in Brazil.
So you have, you could be
a waiter in a restaurant,
maybe you drive a truck,
maybe you're a contractor,
maybe you work as an
assistant in a shop.
And in fact, these
types of jobs represent
85% of the entire
Brazilian workforce.
And so they decided to focus
on these types of jobs.
And these not only were
the most popular jobs,
but also here the information
transparency was the poorest.
So this was really
an opportunity
to have a hugely broad impact.
Often you'd find
out a worker could
have had a similar job in
their local neighborhood,
but they just had
no way to find it.
Imagine how frustrating
that would be.
So let's talk about
the type of person
who Emprego Ligado
is able to help.
So Fernanda, if we drew her
as an Android-ified cartoon,
would look like this.
And so she's got
a cool pink suit.
And she'd been unemployed for
about three and a half weeks
when she signed up
for Emprego Ligado.
And this time had been
really stressful for her.
She had a family
who depended on her,
and they needed her support.
And she also used to
have a long commute.
And with a city full
of supermarkets,
you'd think it should be easy
for her to find a new job.
But unfortunately, she
hadn't had any luck.
So when Emprego Ligado
got started in 2012,
they built a full
featured job search system
using just text messaging.
So think about the last
text message that you sent.
Maybe it was like, LOL,
OMG, or a couple of emoji.
Now imagine that you are
using the same system
to find qualified
workers meaningful jobs
in their local area.
So this is a big
usability challenge
that they managed to overcome.
So I want to walk
you through what
Fernanda did with the system.
So first, she
enters her location.
Then she says that she wants
to work in a supermarket.
She specifies her
desired salary,
and then she starts
getting a list
of jobs matching her criteria.
On average these jobs are
about four kilometers away
from her home, so it's
a big improvement.
Then she can
schedule an interview
or share each different
job with a friend.
She confirms her interview,
she is good to go.
And Emprego Ligado had started
getting some great results
from their SMS-only service.
But you can see that
this process isn't
quite as interactive or as easy
to use as you might want to be.
So they saw another trend.
Android was starting to take
off in Brazil, big time.
And so they saw that this
was an opportunity for them
to build a much more
engaging experience.
So the app launched
in September 2014,
with all the same goals
as the SMS service,
but it's a lot more fun to use.
And they saw that Android
users were actually a lot more
engaged with the service, too.
They were, in fact, applying
to about eight times more jobs
than the average person
on the SMS service.
And the jobs they
apply for tended
to require more
technical skills, too.
They also saw that the
people using the Android app
were actually much younger on
average than the people using
the SMS-only service.
And that's pretty exciting,
because in Brazil there's
actually a very popular
national apprenticeship program.
That's a real big on-ramp
for a lot of young Brazilians
to find a meaningful
career that will take them
far in their lives.
And now they're doing this with
Emprego Ligado to help them.
So far, they've had
a significant impact.
They've had over a million
users through both their SMS
and their Android app services.
And they've been able to
match about 8 million jobs
to their users search criteria.
And think about what that
would do if that was you.
If your commute time got
reduced by that much,
not only would you
feel more relaxed,
you'd have time
with your family.
But maybe you could even
walk or bike to work,
and that would have a big
impact on your health too.
And then it also had a
big impact on employers.
We talked earlier
about the struggles
that employers would
have with recruitment.
And now it's really helped them
reduce their training costs,
because they're able
to find employees who
have more relevant experience.
And because the commute
times are better,
they're no longer losing so many
employees due to the traffic
problems and the transit time.
And so this is
how Emprego Ligado
is using their disruptive
job matching algorithms
to save millions of dollars
for Brazilian companies
every year on retention
and employee recruitment.
And Emprego Ligado
actually makes
money providing this service.
That's pretty awesome.
And this has allowed them
to expand their own team.
They've now grown to team 40,
and 36 of them are Brazilians.
They get interviewed
on the TV news
regularly about how they're
helping the traffic problem.
They're actually taking
crowded buses off the roads.
So let's go back to Fernanda.
So with Emprego Ligado, she was
able to find a new job really
quickly.
And it was a job that she was
really well qualified for.
And it was much
closer to her home.
So with this extra time
she was able to save,
she could spend more
time with her family,
and really had an
improved quality of life.
So here we have
how Emprego Ligado
is making the Brazilian
job market work better
for everybody.
They're increasing access to
information for both employees
and employers.
Now we're going to move to
a totally different part
of the world, and we're
going to talk about Flipkart
in Bangalore, India.
So has anyone here
used the Flipkart app?
Yeah?
Fantastic.
Well, if you haven't
tried it before,
I'll tell you a little bit
more about what you can buy.
You could get basically
any type of product.
You could get a lamp
for your living room,
you could get a refrigerator,
you could get some new clothes.
And actually, when I was
cruising around the Flipkart
app, I learned about
a new type of product
I'd never even heard of
before-- bike sleeves.
Does any one know these?
Yeah?
These are awesome.
So if you've never
heard of them,
they're something that
you wear on your arms.
They're kind of
like leg warmers,
but you wear them when you're
riding your motorcycle.
And if you want to--
you know, you're more
a minimalist person, you
can choose a basic color
like black or white.
And then if you want to
go a little bit wild,
you can choose these tattoo
printed bike sleeves over here
on the right.
And the reason that
Flipkart sells bike sleeves
is that in India, motorcycles
are an extremely popular way
to get around.
Today we're seeing that in
India about two million cars,
every month, are sold, but
about 12 million motorcycles.
So having the right set
of products that meets
the market's needs is really
key to Flipkart's growth.
And their growth
has been enormous.
As of March this year, they're
moving about $4 billion
of merchandise
annually, and they're
expecting it to double
by the end of the year.
So where's this
growth coming from?
It's coming from mobile.
And the online shopping market
in India is growing huge.
In 2016 there's
going to be about 100
million online shoppers,
and the market's
going to grow by about 50%
for the next four years.
It's going to get up to
about $16 billion in 2018.
And this was all made possible
because of the massive growth
of smartphones.
So next year in India the
number of smartphone users
is actually going to be bigger
than the entire population
of the United States.
This is huge.
And in India mobile
has gotten so popular
that Flipkart's focusing
more and more on apps.
They're making so
much more money.
In fact, their Android app
has about 1.5x higher order
frequency compared
to the desktop web.
90% of their mobile
traffic is on Android.
And so they've taken
the next logical step.
They shut down their
mobile website.
And they said, hey,
just go get our app.
And their sister site,
Myntra, which is actually
owned by Flipkart, took
it one step further,
and on May first this
year, they actually
shut down their
desktop website too.
You just go there and
it says, get our app.
And we're seeing a lot
of similar announcements
across all sorts of
online retailers in India,
because of this massive
growth in mobile.
So one of the reasons that
Flipkart has been so successful
is they know how to
market to people there.
They know how to make
the right things.
But they also know how to make
sense of logistical problems
and how to solve them in a
local way that makes sense.
So I found out about this
group of people recently.
It's a whole
community of people,
and here's what they do.
If you're an office
worker, they go
to your house in the morning,
they pick up a hot cooked lunch
that someone in your
house has made for you,
they deliver it to your desk
hot just in time for lunch.
You eat your lunch, and then
they take your lunch box
back home for you.
And they're called
the dabbawalas,
and they've been doing
this for about 120 years.
In Mumbai, there's
about 5,000 dabbawalas,
and they deliver about
200,000 lunches per day.
It's amazing.
And Flipkart recently
announced that they're
going to be working
with the dabbawalas
to do last mile delivery in
some of India's biggest cities.
And the reason they
wanted to do this
is that the dabbawalas
are basically awesome.
They deliver tons of packages
with nearly zero errors.
In fact, Harvard Business
School did a 2010 case study,
and they compared the
accuracy of the dabbawalas
to the Six Sigma process.
And they said,
yup, it's basically
meeting that same level of
reliability and service.
And so we're seeing
here how Flipkart
is combining new technologies
with local market insights
to create a new market,
a new e-commerce market,
in one of the world's
biggest economies.
So next we're going
to go to Europe.
We're going to go to BlaBlaCar.
And if you haven't
tried them yet,
you should the next
time you're in Europe,
or one of many other places that
we're going to talk about soon.
They're the most successful long
distance ride sharing service.
So when you sign
up for BlaBlaCar,
you have to describe yourself.
OK.
Anyone else in the
audience a Bla?
If you don't know
what that means,
it means you don't like
to talk in the car.
Just don't talk to me.
Maybe you're like
me, and you like
to talk a little bit,
but not the whole time.
And then we probably all
know some in our life
who we'd call a
BlaBlaBla, and that's
someone who just talks non-stop.
So why is this important?
Well, if you are running a
hugely successful long distance
ride sharing service
where the average trip is
about 200 miles, you're
going to quickly learn
that if you stick a
Bla and a BlaBlaBla
together in a car
for 200 miles, you
are going to have two
very unhappy customers.
But, if you have this
algorithm and you
know what questions
to ask, you'll
know that you can just stick
two BlaBlaBlas together,
and maybe you've built
a lifelong friendship.
So let's talk about how
BlaBlaCar works with one
of its most popular routes.
Let's say that I'm a driver.
I have my Renault.
I live in Paris
and I'm going to go back to
my hometown of Rennes, where
I grew up.
Maybe it's for the
holidays, maybe
I'm just making an
impromptu visit to a friend.
And I'm actually going to spend
a lot of money on gas and tolls
to get there.
It's going to be a long drive.
And in fact, the trip may be
so expensive that I can't even
go as often as I'd like to.
So I can just launch
the BlaBlaCar app,
and it'll match me with other
people going the same way.
I don't actually make
money doing this,
but I can offset all of
my costs of gas and tolls.
And I can sell the other
three seats in my Renault
to three other people who
are going on the same trip.
So this is a much
cheaper alternative.
So a train ticket would cost
about three times as much.
A plane ticket would cost
about six times as much.
And if you've ever
had the experience
of buying a train or
plane ticket at absolutely
that last minute,
when it's so critical,
you know that those
costs could be way more.
So it's a good option to have.
And this is the BlaBlaCar team.
They're headquartered in Paris
and it sounds like a really fun
place to work.
One of my favorite
programs I heard about
is called the BlaBla swap.
So they have offices all
over the globe because they
reach so many users.
And if you do a BlaBla
swap, what you can do
is go work in another
company's office for week.
And this helps, not
only you to have fun,
but also to exchange ideas and
best practices between offices.
So BlaBlaCar has made
massive expansions recently.
They're now reaching
about two million people
every single month.
They have about 20
million members,
and they're reaching
19 different countries.
So they're all over Europe,
but also in Turkey, Russia,
and most recently,
Mexico and India as well.
And here are the benefits
that BlaBlaCar can bring.
So we talked about the
money savings before,
and that's great.
But it also helps
with the environment.
And it helps with
traffic problems as well.
The average BlaBlaCar
actually has 2.8 people,
up from a typical
average in Europe
of about 1.7 people per car.
And BlaBlaCar's had Android
apps for a long time,
since back in 2010.
And they found that
their mobile experience
means people can book rides
easily at the very last minute.
And because more than
half of their users
are actually on Android,
they've invested a lot
in making some great
Android experiences.
So they made an
Android Wear app here.
It allows you to see when
someone is trying to link up
with you to arrange a ride.
And they did a material
design refresh of their app
recently as well.
It's gotten some
great user feedback.
They're also going to add
a new feature soon called
Meet My Co-Rider.
So this is a neat
feature where it'll
allow co-riders to temporarily
share their locations.
So this way they can see each
other as dots on the map,
and it makes it a lot easier to
try to meet up with somebody.
So the CEO of BlaBlaCar says
that people join because they
want to save money.
That makes sense,
that's a logical reason.
They want to travel
more often, and they
don't want to spend too much.
But they keep using it,
not because of the money,
but because it
allows them to make
social connections that they
never would have had before.
I thought that BlaBlaCar
was going to be basically
just college students.
Right?
That's kind of who
you'd expect to take it.
And there are some
college students.
But if you look at
their demographics,
they're actually
reaching all sorts
of different age brackets.
Typically, actually,
it's the older drivers
who have the cars, and the
younger riders who pay to ride.
And so it's an
interesting way to create
these different
intergenerational connections
that never would have
actually happened before.
So when you use
BlaBlaCar, you save money.
And you usually get
to know somebody,
and you get a good story.
So I want to tell
you one of these.
So there was a guy
who had just retired.
He used to have a big car
to drive around his son, who
did a lot of sports and
had a lot of sports gear
that he needed to carry around.
When his son went off to
school he retired, and said,
I want to spend more time in
Saint-Malo sailing my boat.
Sounds great.
But unfortunately,
he realized that that
was going to be really
expensive and difficult for him
to afford.
So he discovered that BlaBlaCar
would allow him to share rides
with different people.
And that was great.
He got to do a lot more sailing.
But over time, he
realized the thing that
contributed most to having
an enjoyable retirement
was not more time on his boat.
But he created two new
social networks, one in Paris
and one in Saint-Malo
with all the people
he met using BlaBlaCar.
So this is how BlaBlaCar
is connecting the world.
They're making travel
more affordable,
and creating new social
connections because
of information being able to
share easily between people.
So next up we have Dexcom.
They're here too,
today, which is great.
And they're making some of the
world's most advanced blood
glucose monitoring technology.
And their focused on
improving human health
through innovation.
So every time I look at
these stats on the screen,
I get a little bit depressed.
I've looked at them a few times.
29 million Americans have
been diagnosed with diabetes.
And when we say
diagnosed, that means
that there's a lot more people
who have diabetes but are not
diagnosed, or people who
are pre-diabetic and will
become diagnosed soon.
But even still, that 29 million
is 9.3% of the population.
And worse, 200,000 of those
people are under age 20.
It's also led to a
ridiculous amount of cost
in terms of lost wages and
medical expenses in the US.
So if you don't have diabetes
yet you should be happy.
Because it's a lot of work.
I have a few friends
who have diabetes,
and when they're
going through a period
where their diabetes is
getting difficult to control,
they have to test their
blood sugar all the time,
and that could mean
before meals, a few times
after a meal, before
and after exercise,
in the middle of the night,
any time they don't feel well.
And they have to make sure
that their blood sugar doesn't
get too high, and it
doesn't get too low either.
And then the information
that you get back
from a typical blood glucose
test is not very useful.
What does 95 mean?
What's going to happen
a half hour from now?
How do I know if 95 means that
I should eat some candy now,
because my blood sugar's
about to go too low,
or I should take some
insulin, because it's
about to go too high?
And one patient described this
to Dexcom as basically this.
It's like I'm driving down
a winding road at night,
and I only turn on the
headlights occasionally.
That is scary, when your
life could depend on this.
So the Dexcom team thought
that there must be a better way
to be able to deal with this.
So they've created this
continuous glucose monitor.
And you wear it on your
body, as you can see here.
So instead of pricking your
finger a few times every day,
you just get this
continuous graph.
Basically it does the equivalent
of checking your blood
sugar every five
minutes, and it gives you
the full picture of how
your blood sugar is reacting
in terms of, you know,
you eat something,
does it go up and down?
You go and do some
exercise, how does it react?
And this makes it easier
to monitor your diabetes
and keep it under control.
So does anyone here have anyone
in their family with diabetes?
Maybe a friend?
Yeah?
A few people.
I do.
And so this can be
a scary experience
that you have to manage,
especially if that person who
has diabetes is a child.
So Dexcom, next week-- we're
very excited about this--
they're going to be
launching their companion
app on Google Play.
So the whole idea
here is that a parent
could use this app on
their Android phone
to check on their
child's blood sugar.
And they can even get alerts
if that blood sugar goes out
of the safe range.
And this is great
because parents
don't have to buy
a separate device,
or carry it around with them.
They can just use their
existing Android phone
to stay on top of
their kids health.
And finally, we're
incredibly excited
about a special
integration that Dexcom
is doing with Android
Wear's latest technology.
So we now have something
on Android Wear
called direct connect.
And the whole idea here is that
you can connect your Dexcom
monitor to your Android Wear
device, without your phone.
So, why is this really cool?
So imagine that you're a kid in
school and you have diabetes.
And you need to be checking
your blood sugar all the time
to make sure that you stay safe.
And you know before, you'd
have to look at your monitor
all the time.
Imagine being a kid and
you're pulling something
out your pocket that looks
like this all the time.
Other kids are probably
going to be looking at you,
and you may or
may not want that.
Or you could have it
connect to your phone.
And that's definitely
better, and you're pulling
your phone out of your pocket.
That's a bit better, but
it's kind of a hassle.
Maybe the teacher's wondering
if you're texting people.
Right?
So you want to have
something that's more subtle.
And the best option
here is to just have
it go directly to your watch.
So you can just
glance at your watch
as though you were
checking the time.
And you can see if your blood
sugar is staying within range.
That's really awesome.
And it can allow
kids to do things
that they might have felt a
little scared doing before.
Like, if you have a
waterproof Android Wear watch,
you can now use that to check
your blood sugar in the pool,
without even getting out.
Right?
Wouldn't that be great?
You could just go swimming.
And this can be really
critical, because exercise
can be actually one
of the things that
can very quickly push your blood
sugar out of the safe range.
Or imagine that
you're playing soccer,
and you can just
check your watch again
without having to try
to take some big phone
or monitor, and try to clip it
into your clothes somewhere.
It really gives
a lot of freedom.
Or let's say that you
have a really young child.
Maybe that child
might misplace things.
Right?
We all lost things as a kid.
And so if you just
give them a watch,
and they can clip
it onto their wrist,
then they don't have to
worry about misplacing
something expensive.
So this is a glimpse of
what's being possible.
And Dexcom is creating all
these great new accessible and
flexible experiences
that make it a lot more
convenient and a lot
more discreet to keep
an eye on your
blood sugar and be
able to monitor diabetes
and manage it well,
using your smartphone
or your watch,
whatever works well for you.
And they've actually
been able to expand now
to 39 countries globally,
including the US, India,
Europe, and also South America.
And this is saving
families a good bit
of money, because if you already
have an Android, or Android
Wear device, you don't need
to buy something else in order
to do this monitoring.
And you know, Dexcom has made
a huge amount of innovation
here to be able to use
new technologies to make
critical health data
available, and accessible,
and shareable as you
want at any time.
So before we talk
about our next app,
we're going to
have a little quiz.
So does anyone know
which film industry makes
the most movies every year?
Bollywood.
I heard someone say Bollywood.
OK.
Yep.
You get an A, it's Bollywood.
OK, so where is
Hollywood in this list?
Any guesses?
Three.
OK.
Another A. So who
is in number two?
Hollywood, Bollywood,
and who's in the middle?
OK.
It's actually Nollywood.
That's the Nigerian
film industry.
And not only are they number two
in terms of the number of films
made, they're also
number three globally
in terms of the revenue
in their film industry.
And so we're going to talk
about an app called Afrinolly
based in Lagos, Nigeria, which
is a mobile entertainment app.
So Nollywood makes about
1,000 movies per year,
and they have a pretty low
average production cost.
And they've grown so popular
that they've actually
become the second largest
employer in all of Nigeria.
And so directors
recently have been
focused on making even higher
quality production value films,
using new technology to have
very high resolution video
and audio, and producing
great experiences.
So what doesn't make sense here?
We have 173 million
people in Nigeria,
and we have 50 movie theaters.
So how does that even work?
Right?
What's going on?
And what we learned is
that the Nigeria movie
culture is based around DVDs.
And this can work really well.
You go to a city
or town in Nigeria,
there's often stores and
even people in the streets
selling DVDs.
And it's basically great.
Until DVD making technology
got way cheap, maybe
even too cheap.
And the problem now is that
there's a serious problem
with piracy of Nollywood DVDs.
So if you're a
filmmaker in Nigeria,
you can actually have
a serious problem
in terms of making money
to be able to create
more great films.
So the makers of Nollywood
saw this problem.
But again, they also
saw an opportunity.
Because there was a new trend
also happening in Nigeria.
And yep, it's the
mobile phones again.
Almost every adult in
Nigeria has a mobile phone,
and smartphones are
growing really quickly too.
They're also seeing a lot higher
rates of mobile data access,
and a lot of adults in Nigeria
also get great WiFi service
when they're at work, too.
So this meant a new way
for Nollywood directors
to distribute their films
to all of their fans.
And so it's also easier
for Nollywood films
to reach the global
fanbase more quickly.
So people in Nigeria
are obviously
fans, but also people
all over Africa,
and Brazil is also a huge
market for Nollywood films too.
So Afrinolly won the
Android Developer Challenge
four years ago, in 2011.
And the founders got
the idea for their app
because they saw some data
on the top Google searches
all over Africa.
And a lot of them were searches
about Nollywood movies.
But at the time, there was
no IMDb for African cinema,
there really wasn't
anywhere to send people.
So they decided to
create something,
and they built Afrinolly to
make this information broadly
available.
So they won the big
prize here, $25,000,
and they decided to invest
that money in marketing
the new Afrinolly app.
And today Afrinolly is
basically your typical startup.
They started with a
handful of people, now
they have a team of 12.
They're all based
in Lagos, Nigeria.
And their technical team, five
people there on the right,
are responsible for building
the Afrinolly app, as well
as all of the technical services
that Afrinolly works with.
So we said that Afrinolly
started out as a place
to read about the latest
Nollywood news and gossip,
but now their app has over
four million downloads,
and Android is their
fastest growing platform.
And this has been building
on the massive growth
of Android in Nigeria
and the rest of Africa.
So of course, the set of
features that they offer
have grown, too.
In addition to
news, you can also
watch the latest Nollywood
trailers and other video
content.
And now they're about
to take the next step.
We mentioned before
the piracy problem,
and how they want to
help people make money
so that they can
make more films.
So they're going to
be able to let people
by full-length movies
within the Afrinolly app.
This is going to create a new
revenue stream for filmmakers,
and people can either
stream these movies
or download them, at
work, maybe on the WiFi,
and then watch them
at home offline.
So they had this app,
and they wondered well,
let's say that--
what if we imagine
a world where most
of the movie viewing
happened on mobile phones.
What would be the best sort
of content format for that?
And they thought
about short films.
And that was cool, because
a lot of young directors
make short films as well.
It's a great way for
people to get started.
But the problem is, there wasn't
a well established framework
in the customer's mind to
actually be able to make money
on short films.
So they started a
short film competition,
and they now giveaway $100,000
worth of prizes every year.
In the first year they
got 500 submissions
from African filmmakers
in 14 different countries.
And then the Ford
Foundation actually
gave them a grant
to train and mentor
young filmmakers who had
been part of the short film
competition.
And they ended up
making a series
of films designed to drive
social change in West Africa.
And these films
are now distributed
through the Afrinolly app.
So, maybe we can
try to load this.
We have no slide.
Hey.
All right, all right.
I'm going to describe
what's on the slide.
So what we're seeing
in our mind's eye
is something called
the Afrinolly space.
So it's really cool.
You get to see video studios--
we're going to go back.
All right, we're
going to go back.
So you get to see video studios.
You get to see lots
of places to work.
You get a high
tech editing space,
where you can use a high
bandwidth connection and a lot
of advanced video equipment.
And you know, they're able
to basically give filmmakers
a place to be creative.
And so they're
going to start doing
something new in the
Afrinolly space this year.
They're actually going
to start teaching coding.
They're going to give a coding
class to a bunch of high school
students, and they're actually
going to teach more than coding
to them, too.
They're going to be able to
learn how to do filmmaking,
how to do cinematography,
screenwriting, and more.
And so they're hoping that
a lot of these young people
will be able to create
high quality films,
not only when they're
teenagers, but actually
going to pursue careers in
the film industry in Nigeria.
So that's how Afrinolly
is using mobile technology
to be able to connect
film fans with filmmakers
in a new way that
would never have
been possible before
a few years ago.
So now we're going to
talk about Aviro Health.
I'm happy that their
slide got to be
on the screen for a
little bit longer,
because they're pretty awesome.
So-- whoa.
All right.
So they built an app,
and the whole idea
is that it's able to give nurses
up-to-date decision support
to prescribe the right
anti-viral drugs for HIV
patients.
And they've been working with
a developer called Mobile
Kinetics based in Romania.
And they're also
working on a new app
to be able to connect
nurses with experts
to consult on the most complex
HIV cases that they have.
All right.
Everyone cross your fingers.
Think good thoughts.
Hey, fantastic.
Has anyone here tried DuoLingo
to learn a new language?
I've tried it, to brush
up on my rusty French.
Fantastic.
So it is now used by 95 million
people to learn a language,
completely for free.
And learning a language
can be really fun.
But it can do so much more.
Learning a new language can
also break down barriers
and increase social
mobility for people.
I learned, talking to their
CEO, that there's actually
a billion people
globally who are
learning English to
be able to get a job
and improve their life.
So DuoLingo's going to be able
to help them get to that goal.
And education, we've
seen, is a lot better
when we have students, teachers,
and parents all connected
and on the same page.
And Remind has made
a new app that's
been able to connect 35% of
all US K through 12 teachers
with their students and parents
to have engaging conversations.
RunKeeper and LoseIt have
used new Google Fit technology
to create a
personalized work out.
They can measure
which doughnut you ate
and then tell you
exactly how far you have
to run to burn it back off.
And Go-Jek in Indonesia
has made a service
that's now the
fastest way around--
to get around Jakarta or other
Indonesian service cities.
They have over 3,000
registered drivers today.
We also have Mango Health.
We have Jumia.
We have Best Fiends,
raising money for malaria.
We have WeVideo.
And I could go on for
basically the rest of the day,
talking about all the
different developers
that we have here who
are trying to have
a positive impact on the world.
So today's 13-year-olds don't
have a SPARCstation, right?
They have this, they have
access to this thing.
And they grew up thinking
it's normal to have
an app like Mango
Health that reminds you
to take a critical medication.
Or an app like
Go-Jek, that means
that when you go to Indonesia
you can summon a motorcycle
taxi like that.
And they're starting to do some
pretty cool stuff with that.
I think back to my
13-year-old self,
my SPARCstation, my blue links.
And I wrote a paper.
But these kids are doing
so much more than that.
Here are three teenage
siblings in Georgia.
So their parents worked
in corporate America
and managed software developers.
They saw all the benefits that
these software developers were
getting by having those
skills, and always encouraged
their kids to study
computer science,
even from an early age.
And as many of you know,
the world where we live,
it's not perfect.
And recently in the
US we've had a lot
of concerns around law
enforcement and civil rights.
So these teenagers, in response,
decided to build an app.
Because that's what we do today.
And they're enabling
people to understand
what their rights are.
And they're also able to
share their experiences
with law enforcement, both
positive and negative.
The experience here is
to improve transparency
in the whole process, and
to give a voice to people
who didn't have one before.
So in case you're
wondering, this app
now has an average rating of
4.5 stars, and tens of thousands
of installs.
These young developers have shed
light on an important issue,
and it's really powerful.
So when I was 13, I
wanted more people
to have access to
information so that they
could empower themselves
and their communities.
And I can't wait to see
what the world looks
like when these teenagers
here are up on this stage
telling their story.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]